this is shirt club um yeah let me show
you got that right okay forget title
like that um this is an episode where
Stephen uh he wants to get his dance
guitar lessons out he makes these little
flyers and one of largest friend season
says let's make this into iron let's
make this into a big t-shirt thing like
am i it's so weird that kid is not like
a variation of garnet or something cuz
every time I hear of Tonka the way it
looks I'm like that I think garnet to
that that bunch of kids I mean they all
returned toxic puts me to sleep I'm like
alright so he's also the the son of the
mayor so he wants to turn into art and
he wants to get out there and it's kind
of a so bad it's good thing where it's
like he doesn't see how you think really
that precious alright they he are so
nice yes so naive said it's so funny
um and so gets out there and everyone's
kind of laughing at and stuff like that
nobody's taking lessons so to get his
revenge Steven shoots this t-shirt kid
everybody has an old piece of art that
he drew for his dad this is to vote for
him and the kid starts crying whether
that's a tear of like anger or tear of
happiness I can't tell um but he goes
and he gets a guitar lesson from his dad
uh nice little ending um and that's
about it I did I don't know if it's
because like we're both kind of under
the weather of the moment we had a 15
hour shoot yesterday yeah so I think I
don't after yeah I know it's bad and the
vago we're kind of sick or yeah I kind
of like watch this episodes like alright
I autumn like I just couldn't really
drive up any energy for this episode
wait huh you know it's one where when I
was watching and I was kind of like well
so like I'm hearing it kinda has ideas
and stuff but I'll just be very honest I
don't know if it was something that I
like got you know it's like it seems
like there was something really deep
going on there if it was kind of half or
if it's just silly
yeah like or both or whatever I'm not
saying that's bad at
all you know of anything I like was a
bad answer I just think that was kind of
like there's some things that happen
yeah we're something like we're uh
Stephen County fused together and they
go out like that was you know just the
right amount of kind of vagueness that
hey this could be taken for a lot of
various things we're with this one it
was just it was so odd that like it just
the serve motivations of everybody
wanting to like this to dislike it or
vice versa and is like I don't know I
guess it's kind of like what they do
with YouTube celebrities kind of are the
ones that become fast for just a quick
arrest popular fast for just doing
something silly show yourself
mmm um but yeah it's one of those things
but okay but even like Tommy also like
people would buy his movie and they
would watch it and stuff like that where
with with this it's kind of like it's
nobody's taking the lessons you know
that that's kind of things I guess yeah
I don't so answer I don't know quite
what we're going forward yeah I said I
guess I don't know that's a good thing
or a bad thing like I don't think it's a
bad thing
maybe it's so open-ended we're just
idiots maybe maybe you like your own the
countess just gonna get so obviously
this um but let you tell it's a metaphor
for the Holocaust so um I mean it's not
something at all where I'm like wow
there's nothing here this is just dead
no ideas as I know there definitely are
I just can't say for certain what they
are like it does you like just you it
yeah like that fusion episode no I I
feel like this was a draft one of a
script and it needed a draft today yeah
like I like this a bunch of ideas here
now you just need to polish it up
somehow
yeah like focus it a little bit but I I
don't know maybe was something really
going on here that I'm missing but yeah
but this is what I see it seems vaguely
flourish like you know unless somehow it
comes back and it turns out the t-shirts
were a gateway to another dimension that
was the best scene when they were all
like did the t-shirts come to life and
are like eating people you know is
dreams obvious is it no it's just
misappropriating my artwork
oh well that's that was great boss oh I
love that yeah
you know this is actually one it might
be open the floodgates here but this is
what actually I wouldn't mind hearing
white people's interpretation of what
what they got out of it because it's one
where I just sort of saw it I was like
okay like that's please don't start off
with you assholes , yeah we already know
that yeah I mean there's no debating
that um but yeah it's something where I
wouldn't mind that you can't see people
be like well this is kind of what I got
of and this wasn't interesting take on
this or well I thought it was about uh
so I mean yeah whatever your thoughts on
uh you know the point of the comments
cuz yeah I'm actually kind of curious I
like to know what people got out of it
um and like I said I don't I don't hate
it I don't love it it's just one of
those where I can't watch it you say one
okay well that happened but but yeah
Joel yes
but it's obviously not devoid of ideas
either it's not like a oh this is a
complete waste of time it's like know
that there's something here you can
definitely censor something here it's
just it is it realizes it hitting people
uh in a way and tends I do whenever he
pops up like wanna see an invention
exchange like I Nemus yeah if this is
canisters it's the shirt cannons sirs
and this is actually a reverse t-shirt
this shirt where's you what do you think
sirs it if I that like just for a few
seconds that Lars and what's it the
other guy god I'm not okay I'm not
joking and I know that the few fans of
Lars and Ronaldo be like God will they
shut up about this today where I can't
rub in our head Lars oh no Lars
yeah Lars shows up with his end and
there's with his yeah with this bromance
with the mayor's kid and like the few
ideas I just sat them like god I
yes and then like Ronaldo shows up and
they fire the cannon ever and although
it's like he's it a message from space
what are you trying to say that was just
like God I him too and done just started
laughs yeah just like no cuz it's like I
feel it man I feel it but Lars I can
tolerate more Ronaldo was annoying me
even you ask her it's like that they're
not in it long but even those few
seconds yes I hate talking like that you
know I hate like you know or just say
what can you take a few seconds I just
sounds so snobby and every you know what
I can't fail it's just no one donation
was just like how can I not like this
dude what's a minute I'm like I'm having
no obligation like every character on
the show it's just not and neither are
you like their characters you probably
run into all the time in movies or
cartoon shows or something that just
like god I really hate that guy it's the
same ear I'm not saying it's always
logical there are times when Lars is
being perfectly reasonable and I'm just
like I hate it assistance so it
just happens that art and if you like
him like him
yeah if you like him I don't care yeah
we're not giving like no you're yeah I
always if you go go like what do you
think about that good for you yeah like
him why do you like something um but uh
yeah so that's that's about it I mean on
to much else yeah this one obviously
doesn't time to like a bigger plot that
we know of or anything like that but uh
yeah leave your thoughts in the comments
about what you think like the episode
was about or like just what you got out
of it I think is the the bigger thing so
um that's about it and we'll see if the
next one later
woo